IAN
Aliens are out there, dude!
TRACE
I know they are!
I did the math.
IAN
Ahem.
TRACE
Maths.
Ugh.
TRACE
Hey hoomons, Trace here for DNews.
Finding extra-terrestrial beings is not entirely
science fiction, it's more like science…
uh.
Science Wait-and-see-but-it's-totally-going-to-happen.
It's a mathematical inevitability.
IAN
It's true, but there are still some problems.
In 1959, the journal Nature published a paper
that found satellite dishes, which are basically
electromagnetic wave antennas, had become
sensitive enough that if pointed in the right
place, they MIGHT pick up alien communications.
TRACE
A year later, a Cornell astronomer named Frank
Drake did so… kicking off the now-famous,
Search for ExtraTerrestrial Intelligence,
or SETI.
And then a year after that, he created the
Drake Equation.
IAN
The Drake Equation basically breaks down the
Milky Way into numbers to arrive at an estimate
of how many communicating alien civilizations
might be out there.
The Drake Equation considers the following
factors:
TRACE & IAN (alternate)
The average rate of star formation
The fraction of those stars with planets
The average number of potentially habitable
planets around those stars
The fraction of those planets which can support
life
The fraction that actually DO develop life
The fraction of those with life that evolved
to be intelligent and civilized
The fraction of civilized intelligent life
that have developed communications
And finally, the length of time it takes those
intelligent aliens to transmit a signal into
space.
TRACE
And this was all designed to put an estimate
on the number of developed, intelligent, communicative,
civilizations which are out there waiting
for us to find…
IAN
But obviously, there are some problems with
this formula.
It’s basically taking a bunch of unknowns
and throwing them into an equation that can
give a huge range of probabilities.
But even Drake didn’t intend for this equation
to be a definitive answer as to whether or
not aliens with radio dishes are REALLY out
there.
It's supposed to help us start the conversation
about the sheer NUMBER of planets which could
have life.
TRACE
Interestingly as time goes on and advances
in astronomy come in thick and fast, we’re
gradually refining our estimates on how many
exoplanets are out there in the galaxy…
IAN
And there’s a LOT.
NASA’s Kepler space telescope is even finding
worlds orbiting within their star’s “habitable
zones” that are possibly cosy places for
life to evolve.
The upshot is that the more real data that
we can throw into this equation, the more
compelling it becomes.
But there are other factors that the Drake
Equation doesn’t consider, one of them being:
how do non-living chemicals turn into living,
breathing, creatures that eventually evolve
to build radio transmitters?
TRACE
Now, there’s another equation which uses
planetary chemistry to calculate the odds
that life could form on a planet at all!
IAN
It's almost like this new Scharf-Cronin equation
is one of the missing puzzle pieces from the
Drake equation!
TRACE
The Scharf-Cronin uses the total number of
building blocks on given planet, and multiplies
it by the fraction of building blocks needed
per "organism", multiplies that by the availability
of those building blocks during the time they
exist, and then the probability of the assembly
of those blocks in a given time, and then
multiplies that by time overall.
IAN
From that, it can determine a rough estimate
of the odds that an origin-of-life event would
happen on a planet!
Turning non-living chemicals into a functioning
biology is called “abiogenesis” and this
new equation provides us with new microscopic
areas to study, beyond the Drake Equation,
if we are to identify where life could possibly
gain a foothold.
TRACE
Equations like these are starting points for
scientists to figure out what we need to know
to find answers like, "are we alone?"
Without the Drake and now the Scharf-Cronin
equations we wouldn't have a model to start
with, in finding out how many planets might
have life out there.
IAN
THIS is the bleeding-edge of science in some
ways.
Just a bunch of people... sitting around,
thinking about how we can figure out the answer
to The Big Questions.
TRACE
So, how do we know life exists?
Because mathematically speaking it probably
does, maybe not Drake-level communicative
life, perhaps it's microroganisms, or maybe
plants!
But, in the end, the 1959 paper by Cocconi
and Morrison put it best in it's very last
line, "The probability of success is difficult
to estimate, but if we never search, the chance
of success is zero."
IAN
One way life could have found its way to our
planet, might have been via PANSPERMIA.
TRACE
My, gosh Ian!
Whatever could that be?!
IAN
You can watch this video and find out!
TRACE
Do you think life exists out there?
Tell us about it in the comments and PLEASE
subscribe for more dnews.
If you want more space stories from Ian click
over to our new website Seeker.com!